tell me about Sheikh jarah the
neighborhood in East Jerusalem where you
grew up has you know in a way a typical
neighborhood despite the despite the
Absurd reality that surrounds it it's a
typical neighborhood in terms of
Palestinian neighborhoods is one that is
threatened with
colonialism with settler expansion and
with forced expulsion and it has been
that way since the early 70s my family
like all of the other families
were expelled from their homes in the
nakabe in 1948 and they were forced out
by the hagana and other
Zionist paramilitaries that later formed
the Israeli military
and they were driven to various cities
and
my grandmother moved from City to city
and she ended up in 1956 Silverado has
established as a refugee housing unit
by the United Nations and by the
Jordanian government which has which had
control over that part of Jerusalem at
the at the time
and then people lived there
harmoniously they were all from
different parts of Palestine
and you know they managed to rebuild
their lives after the first explosion
and then in the 70s you had cellular
organizations
um many of whom were registered here in
New York and in the United States
claiming our houses and our lands as
their own by Divine decree and because
obviously because the judges are Israeli
and the Lords were written by Israeli
settlers and the whole Judiciary was
established
Atop The the rubble of our homes and
villages we had no
you know we had no real pull in the
courts the Israeli courts would look at
the Israeli documents which we argue are
falsifies and fabricated
um and they would take them at face
value without authentication and they
refused to look at our documents they'll
just look at the documents from the
Jordanian government the documents from
the U.N the documents from the ottoman
archives so you already have this kind
of asymmetry in the court that for any
person with common sense would lead you
to believe that this is not in fact a
legal battle
um or a real estate dispute as the
Israeli Ministry of Foreign Affairs
likes to frame it but rather a very very
political battle one that is about
social engineering one is about
demographics one that is about removing
as many Palestinians as possible from
occupied Jerusalem
um so we did what all Palestinian
families in Jerusalem do when they're
faced with this kind of threat and we
bought time we we pleaded and pleaded
and appealed the courts and appealed the
cases and we got over 50 expulsion
orders
um in 2009
rifle wielding settlers
accompanied by police and Israeli
military came over
and shoved our neighbors outside of
their home around 5am it's like
it was the most
brutal violent thing I'd seen as a child
at the time and I didn't realize that my
turn was coming my turn was next they
threw they threw them out in the middle
of the night with sound bombs and rubber
bullets and they
had to live in tents on the street
for many many months and even lived in
our front yards for a few months and
lived in their cars
process 2009 you said 50 expulsion
orders what uh what was happening
between the 70s and 2009 there had been
many dozens of explosions orders against
us and against many other families in
the in the neighborhood 28 other family
20 28 families in total actually
um and in 2008 2009 the first wave of
explosions finally happened it actually
began with a
on camera code were not related but we
live on the same street in the same
neighborhood she was thrown out of her
home
um her husband an elderly man also named
was pronounced dead on the spot he had a
stroke and died he they the Israeli
soldiers pulled him out of his home
while he was urinating and threw him
into the streets and he died a few
months later the rawi and the hanoon
families which are you know kind of not
a clan but you know in Palestine you
have sometimes a building that contains
multiple brothers and their wives
um each have little apartments so the
royal family is about 35 people were
thrown out in the middle of the street
right across from us
and then by the end of 2009 I had come
home from school to find all of my
furniture scattered across the length of
the street and I saw the settlers many
of whom had American accents
living in our house
and their justification for this their
reasoning for this is you know Divine
decree this is this is what God wants
this is the promised land this is so and
so as if God is some kind of real estate
agent
um
so they took over half of our home and
we continued to be in courts for the
following decade this was I was still a
child and I had broken English and I was
talking to all of these diplomats and
all these journalists
who would you know subjugate me
um to their subject me to their you know
racism and biases and and so on and so
forth and he had to prove my Humanity
time and time again and they had to you
know do all of this all with broken
English
and we were lucky even if we got a if we
got a quote in the in the article
written about us by the times or so on
and so forth
move forward to 2020 I was in New York
City studying um a master's degree
getting a master's degree and
my father calls me
and he told me you know we haven't yet
another expulsion order and we decided
to launch a campaign
it was quite ambitious at the time
but the whole objective of the campaign
was to demystify what is happening right
because it's reported on in the news
it's reported on
around the world as this real estate
dispute as these evictions which was not
really what's happening evictions do not
entail
a foreign army in an occupied territory
forcibly removing you out of your home
uh so I came home from New York and we
launched a campaign which turned into a
global success and I believe it was a
global success because finally the the
images on the screen matched the
rhetoric that was being said it wasn't
so confusing or complicated anymore
all of this asymmetry was pronounced and
articulated in a way that
any of you or be it in Alabama be it in
New York be it in Egypt was able to
understand the asymmetry of the digi of
the judicial system and you know the
agenda of colonialism that was taking
place here
and due to immense International and
diplomatic pressure
um from all over the world even the
United States
the Israeli Supreme Court was forced
to cancel all of the eviction orders
until further notice this I consider was
a small victory because obviously we are
still at risk of losing our homes once
they decide to do the land registry
which we can get into a little bit later
if you'd like
um
but nonetheless it was something that we
haven't seen
before and the fact
that the Supreme Court canceled all of
these dozens and dozens of past eviction
orders it's set a precedent and it also
proved that this was a political battle
not a legal one so let's just add a
little more detail to the people who are
not familiar with the story with the
region
with the evictions for the courts so
first of all Shake Your Eyes in East
Jerusalem maybe you can say what is
Jerusalem where is it located
what are we talking about in terms of
regionally and second what kind of
people that live there so if you could
talk about the Palestinian people
and
um we should also make clear that these
evictions is literally people living in
homes and their homes are taken away
from them
I suppose technically it's legal
uh evictions but you're saying that
there's a asymmetry of power in the
courts where the legal is uh not so much
legal but is politically and maybe even
religiously based
yeah I mean the biggest the most
important context here is that
oftentimes Americans think that Israel
and Palestine are some kind of two
neighbor two neighboring countries
um
that live next to each other and they
are at War but the fact of the matter is
Palestinian cities exist
um all over the country and it's just
one country it's just one infrastructure
and Israel is literally on top of
Palestine it was established on top of
our Villages
um in the late 40s uh now according to
international law the eastern part of
Jerusalem is under occupation so Israeli
presence
over the area it's completely
illegitimate they say the evictions are
legal because the settlers
write their laws so obviously they're
going to allow settlements to expand but
according to international law according
to even U.S policy
um
Israel occupies the eastern part of
Jerusalem it's jurisdiction there is
illegitimate we shouldn't even be going
to their courts in the first place but
we have no other option
we're talking about generations and
generations and generations of people
who have lived there
for the longest time who now even though
you know for example me I don't have a
citizenship I'm a resident a mere
resident I have a blue ID card even
though my grandmother and my grandfather
were born in Jerusalem their
grandparents were born in Jerusalem
um even though you've lived there for
Generations but Palestinians in
Jerusalem we are not Citizens We're just
mere residents same thing with residents
of the occupied Syrian Golan they are
not citizens they are just residents in
their own hometowns this is an important
piece but all of this gets convoluted
and Lost in Translation and I think
I I would argue it's a lot more it's
a lot of the time it's dubious it's it's
malicious the fact that these little
pieces of context that frame the entire
story get lost
you know I'll talk to you about
something else
um just 10 minutes 10 minutes across
from my neighborhood there's another
neighborhood called silhouan and the
people in silhouan are also threatened
with expulsion but not through evictions
but through home demolitions and if you
look at American state American Media or
Israeli stiff media you would read the
headlines you know Palestinians living
in homes built illegally are gonna face
you know their homes are going to be
torn apart
what these headlines don't tell you and
even sometimes most of the time the
substance doesn't tell you that
Palestinians seldom ever get
building permit applications
um in fact recently a spokesperson for
the Israeli military confirmed that was
95 of building permits applications
submitted by Palestinians in is
Jerusalem and the West Bank are rejected
by the Israeli authorities and to make
this even more absurd the guy
the councilman who is responsible
for rejecting and accepting building
permit applications his name is Jonathan
Youssef and he's a he's a an activist in
the settler movements and he's a
Jerusalem council member
and he last week following the expulsion
of uh
sublaban family and the old city of
Jerusalem he posted to his official
Facebook account
demanding a second promising another
nakaba he has done so on many occasions
he has chanted with a megaphone just a
few months ago walking down the street
in my neighborhood same thing we won't
knock by now this is a man who has
vandalized their murals who has screamed
islamophobic slurs this is literally a
man in the government making these
decisions right uh and this is similar
to you know myself in the South Hebron
Hills for those who don't know it's uh
it's it's a place in the occupied West
Bank where Bedouin and um cave dweller
Palestinians have lived for Generations
they have cultivated the land
um and recently they were expelled from
their homes over a thousand people were
expelled from their remote small
villages again if you're reading
American Media they would say it would
say Palestinians living in firing zones
were removed because they're living in a
military zone what these media reports
will not tell you that in the 80s the
Israeli government
purposefully classified many lands in
the occupied West Bank
as firing zones as off limit military
zones for the sole purpose of expelling
the residents and this is not some kind
of conspiracy theory this is
Declassified information that was
released from the Israeli State archive
that was later reported on by her audits
also these reports will not tell you
that the judge
who rules on whether these people
continue to live under homes or not is
himself a settler in the West Bank I'm
not even talking about
you know a loose definition of a settler
but according to international law this
is a settler living illegally in an
illegal settlement in the occupied West
Bank this is the Judiciary
um that we deal with which is hilarious
considering how it's being reported on
um in American Media recently as some
kind of Beacon of progress and democracy
that the new government is trying to
undermine so there's no representation
in the courts for the Palestinian people
I mean we have lawyers but no there is
no there's no in fact there is for
Palestinians with Israeli citizenships
for example there's over 60 laws that
specifically and explicitly
discriminates against them
so again it's technically legal the
evictions and the demolitions yeah so
was Jim Crow was legal also you know
when something is legal it can also
still be
wrong absolutely history has shown us
time and time again
um that legality does not necessarily
mean morality and the law you know is uh
the law is a bloodbath in many ways it
has been used
and abused to facilitate the most
horrendous atrocities in in the case of
the Palestinians the law has served to
facilitate and bureaucratize our ethnic
cleansing
do you think there's people
judges and just people in power in the
Judiciary that have hate for the
Palestinian people
I mean I'm not really yeah the the easy
simplistic answer is yes but I don't
really care about the contents of their
hearts what I care about the policy they
enact right the laws they write and
enact are hateful demolishing a person's
home
um so you can have somebody from Long
Island New York
who is fleeing you know fraud charges
um this is the case in my house live in
in their in their you know front yard
that's hateful so I don't need you know
confirmation this is something we see a
lot actually you know
um Palestinians and people who are
pro-palestine and just people who want
to make a difference in how this cause
is represented
we often Run for the first
um
opportunity to cite an Israeli being
hateful you know the recent the last uh
Israeli Prime Minister said that he has
killed many Arabs and that he has no
qualms with it
um Netanyahu has said a slew of racist
hateful things
um Joe rochinsky the pioneer of Zionism
herzl one of the pioneers of Zionism all
have said horrible hateful
things we also like cannot wait to you
know
cite uh a confession from a former
Israeli soldier who is guilty
Consciousness keeping them you know up
at night and we use all of these you
know
confessions or slip UPS as evidence to
prove that this is a racist country that
is an acting race racist acts but we
don't need this because the material
proof is on the ground you see it in the
policies that are enacted you see it
um in how the country how this regime
has behaved for the past 75 years I
don't need you know
confessions from the likes of Netanyahu
to understand that his heart is full of
hate
so if you could return to 1948 and
describe something that you've mentioned
the nakba which means catastrophe in
Arabic
what was this event what was this
displacement in this possession of
Palestinians in 1948
well you know like May 15 1948
um
is commemorated every year as you know
the anniversary of the knuckleberry but
I would even argue and I think this is
like an
a very popular
idea is that the nakaba did not begin or
end in 1948 the 48 was rather you know a
crystallization
of the Zionist Enterprise in Palestine
um and what what happened was that
many zionists
paramilitaries that again today emerged
and made the Israeli Army which calls
itself the Israeli Defense Forces even
though they're literally always
aggressor
um
committed atrocities and massacres and
you know they
destroyed over 500 Villages they killed
over 15 000 people they forced
a very large portion a majority of the
Palestinian population
uh to flee their homes and this was you
know
the near total Destruction of
Palestinian society that continues on to
this day we refer to it as the ongoing
nakba and you see it in in you see it in
Siloam you see it and everyone and all
of these people losing their homes and
in many cases time and time again you
know I grew up and my grandmother told
me the stories about the naked she told
me stories about her neighbors who
were
running away in a panic and they had
mistaken a pillow for their offspring
and they just took it with them and they
realized later that they forgot their
child and they came back for many many
people who were separated from their my
grandmother herself she lost her husband
for a few months for nine months he was
imprisoned by the Israelis
um
you know she told me all of these
stories and she wasn't just reminiscing
about them she was
you know
letting me know that this is still
happening and then and I didn't need to
grow up that old to see it happening in
my own front yard to see that expulsion
happened in the same fashion she's she's
talked about it but
you know now they have replaced their
artillery with the Judiciary
um they have replaced you know the the
the slashing of the pregnant women's
bellies in the Daria scene Massacre with
with laws that say you know you're not
you're not legally allowed to be here
we're gonna kick you out of your home
and it's happening and it has happened
in in
in broad daylight
um one piece of context for The Listener
who doesn't who is not familiar with the
knuckleberry
is the welfare declaration
which was a promise quote unquote
promise made by the British
to the Zionist movement in 1917
uh committing to The Establishment I'm
quoting I think word for word committing
to the establishment of a Jewish state
in Palestine
um as if Palestine was you know the
British to give away
um and there was this whole movement
that called for colonization of
Palestine and there were different there
were different schools of thought in
Zionism you know people like zanguo said
that this was a country without a people
um and Palestinians who have existed
there who have cultivated the lands who
have you know
had diverse cultural and religious and
political
practices they were completely erased
and other people like zobozinski
um
were a lot more explicit and a lot more
honest and said that we need to fight
the Palestinians because they love their
land much like the red Indians love
their lands and he had a paper called
The Iron Wall colonization of Palestine
must go forward
um
and all of these all of these schools of
thoughts were then shopping around for
you know Imperial support
uh for their cause
they tried they tried to get support
from the Ottoman Empire
um they tried to get support from
Germany and this is in the 1800s and
then they got support from the United
Kingdom a great book to recommend is the
100 year the Hundred Years War on
Palestine
um that's the you know traces designist
movement oftentimes in designists own
words
um and so today what we're seeing is a
continuation and you know people like
zabotinski who are like profoundly and
explicitly racist who have called for
genocide who have uh called the
Palestinians barbaric who have
said and done
racist things you know Japanese also was
like the founder of the ergon one of the
other militias that later merged to
become the ID the Israeli Army uh which
was responsible for the Darius in
Massacre which was responsible for the
bombing of the King David Hotel
um this is a person who's still
celebrated in Israeli Society there are
still streets named after him and
Netanyahu just two weeks ago if I'm not
mistaken honored him in a public
celebration
um so this is Zionism it's not even
through my own
words what he said to people
uh that describe Israel as having a
historical right to the land
so if you stretch not across decades but
across centuries into the past
this kind of thing is a red herring um
it's a destruction because you don't
think of any state
as having rights but there is this
exceptionalism to the Israeli regime
where it is it has a right to defend
itself and it has a right to the land
and it has a right to shoot 14 year old
boys because
it thought they had a knife in their
pockets you know a lot of the time
people cite the Torah on site religious
books and you know sometimes zionists
will even say like read the Quran and
blah blah blah you know regardless of
whatever was written in these books that
were written thousands and thousands of
years ago the fact of the matter is no
one has a right to go on slaughtering
people removing them from their homes
and then continuing to live in their
homes continuing to drink coffee on
their balconies
um decades and decades later with no
shame with no introspection
with no reflection that's no one has the
right to do that no one has the right to
keep an entire population of people in a
cage
uh which is what's happening to people
in the West Bank who have no freedom of
of movement which is what's happening
in Gaza which is blockaded
to water air and land and
is deemed uninhabitable by human rights
organizations like the UN
um no one has a right to do that